我今天在盤中我就做了一個配
盤中呢這個有聽到我們discord都有講到
我今天在那個環宇快要漲停的時候
我做了一個配
叫做環波配
我空了環宇買菠蘿威
各位呢你去看一下我菠蘿威買在1130
環宇空在快漲停
因為今天菠蘿威跌下來這個點我覺得還不錯
我是在做一個1130然後
環雨空在漲停附近
那環雨明天被關了
那又留一個上影線我覺得明天應該走勢比較弱
我環雨大概是空在
空在漲停附近啦
呃我們算638
算640好了比較好算
640 1130
比例大概是1比2
就空環雨兩張然後
買波羅威一張
環波配
超愛做雙刀
雙刀真的很好玩
就是買A空B
像我昨天買景碩空星星
我在禮拜天的高雄營廠上課
我就有講了我說禮拜一我要
買景碩空星星我要這麼做好啊今天在盤中呢我們跟那個盤中的那個discord學友有講我說這個點我覺得環宇跟波羅威這個點太美了
我就空環宇買波羅威
那目前為止是雙賺啦
因為環宇大概空在640附近嘛
那這裡就跌到620了
就賺了快20塊
那波羅威是賺了70塊
你自己看一下 你自己看這時間啦
這個時間齁 這個10點21分
那對應的是懷雨的這個位置
差不多吧
10點21分是在那個快要漲停附近
懷雨跟菠蘿威的相關係數非常高
各位我們來看一下 懷雨跟菠蘿威的相關係數
這一招真的很好用
這一招呢叫做 各位你自己看
懷雨跟菠蘿威長的其實很像
好那這一招呢就是我們這個在處置戰法裡面的經典啦
好那處置戰法呢
這招為什麼我會這麼用喔
其實是因為我用了處置神器
欸處置日報呢會告訴你齁
會告訴你明天呢有哪些股票會被關
條件是什麼
那這個在處置神器裡面
處置神器裡面處置日報
這個我是覺得很值得一做啦
處置真的很好玩
很好玩